so today in today's lecture um
we'll discuss um end games that
occurred in my games some of the games
in the 2020 us championships that i
had an honor to play a few days ago
i think that they were pretty
interesting
i i played
five of those end games i don't think we
have enough time to cover all of them in
detail
however at least uh two or three of them
i hope to cover today
and probably next time when we will uh
during the next lecture
or maybe in the future i don't know
we'll see how it goes
uh we'll cover the rest nonetheless for
now uh i was
i think it's time to start uh
talking about the case of mind in the
first game
it was i played against sam savion and
after a very sharp opening
and complicated fight in the
middle game we achieved the following
position i should
probably flip the board because we are
interested from black's perspective
right now
uh mostly because i play with black
pieces so we got this end game
and objectively is around equal however
at first if only i would be able to
preserve my knight and escape with it
let's say to c5
in the future um i think black would
have had
chances to be better however
it is pretty much infeasible and
as because white can play anyone
basically bishop takes e4 and eliminated
the knight
resulting in the rook and game um
and this is exactly what happened in the
game actually so in the game happened
king g1
and i played movie g6 when natural move
i want to i couldn't play in nc5 right
now
because after sc5 i would have lost the
pawn and
i would be in trouble so i don't want to
allow that
therefore at first i play g6
bishop takes e4 and here i just simply
decided to take
the pawn on e4 however
there was an alternative which was
probably even stronger
however it's would lead to similar
probably outcome
rook fe8 the idea is that i want to keep
two rooks on the board
but i i don't think it changes much and
position still remains
uh equal for instance after c4 i have to
take back on
e4 with the pawn probably or the rook
also
is fine it should be around equal
everything uh but
i but i wish i didn't want to discuss
what had happened in the game because uh
out of nowhere it's the seeming in the
seemingly equal end game
i got into trouble and all the source of
this trouble was because at some point
we both started playing on basically
less than 10 seconds
uh however here we still had uh you know
like few minutes
so let's see how the game followed and
um
what happened that uh such complications
later happened
so king days of eight uh c4 obviously
right now
e3 is a move that i have to play this is
the move i saw that i
uh i thought i had to play when i played
move
f takes e4 otherwise if i play the same
king e7 or something i would
only be worse if he manages to play king
f2 and then why the
king e3 and pawn only 4 will be pretty
much a weakness
therefore i have to make sure that i
prevent his king
from entering to e3 and same time i
advance my pawn and activate my rook
in the game and b3 in strengthening the
pawn structure
and here's the first critical position
because i have a choice there is no kind
of like
pretty much equival the problem is what
to choose here is black
both moves that i have in mind right now
and i had in mind during the game
uh lead to equal position obviously
however
one is a little bit more accurate than
the other uh from
purely practical standpoint so uh
in the game i played rook e4 and the
idea is obviously to simplify the
position of the next a4
and uh you know the game should i for
thinking they should the game should end
to you know
further simplifications and eventually a
draw
and um i was and this is correct
obviously
uh however king e7 there was an
alternative
and i was i was considering this move um
i didn't i wasn't sure whether which one
to choose so i decided to choose to
choose simplicity
and that's why i played rookie four with
idea of a4 however kingston is also very
good the problem is or like why i didn't
play this
is that i was a little bit skeptical of
what happens after moves like g3 or g4
for instance after g3 his idea was
obviously kg duking a3
and the idea to simply win this e3 pawn
if he wins the pawn
and transfers the po and game i'll be
lost pretty much
however there is a very important
move that black has right now and during
the game i didn't quite consider it
and that's the reason why i didn't go
for it and this move is g5
the point is that i try to if he plays
king g2 i play gsmpg4
and i further restrict his king and my
king
if he does he doesn't do anything
special i even have chance to win this
game
if i can bring my kink to f6 f5 e4
machine will be super active pony free
is very strong as well i will
may have chances to win the game so from
if i were
kind of from practical perspective
it would be a pretty good try for me to
let's say maybe
win the game of course potions equal and
with let's say
not so difficult moves like for instance
h3 or and uh right now
king avon bringing him bringing the king
this way
uh he would easily solve his problems or
like not even so
there are any problems like you know the
issue of let's say
uh king invasion of king f6 king f5
and the king comes to e2 rook gets
activated for instance
if king of six uh rook e one king of
five king
two king e4 and rook f1 and he activates
his rook he's definitely not in trouble
anymore
like he never was pretty much and he
activates his rook to f7 or f6
and the position gets a little bit sharp
but
objectively pushes equal and it should
end
in a draw so this was
possible possible to play and
but the very important idea that i
wanted to point out here is again
this idea of g5 value or g4 if someone
may ask
let's what happens after let's say is
otherwise play g4 not to even allow this
if g5 is of course kenji two king of
three well white wins
but g4 on the other hand has this
problem that pawn g4 is a little bit uh
uh exposed and the subject of two
emitted attack with e4
and after h3 or sorry if g5 we can
consider playing
at some point g4 obviously and another
thing is that after
uh king g2 we can take the pawn on g4
after h3
suddenly king f6 could be actually uh
even
possibly better for black um
or at least at any point if i want to be
if i want to be super savers black and
play also a4 and just eliminate all the
pawns so there was actually no need to
play the rookie for
uh therefore uh if i starve king he said
i could
i was i would be completely fine as well
and maybe if he made some mistakes or
maybe we have some chances to win
especially you know with rapid so
anything can happen
however i played move
e4 with idea of simplifying simply the
position of a4 root ac4
king f1 a4 following the plan i root xc4
rook takes uh even after after rook
takes e3 i'll takes a4
there is not much to discuss pretty much
i think because uh
i play next move rook b4 or rook d4 i
eliminate one of his pawns
and that for example like would follow
with rook c3 rook before
check wins the pawn but let's say h5
for instance and i will collect the five
point at some point
upon the b pawn was not going anywhere
uh
white's king is very passive there is no
way that white can win this position is
pretty much just a draw
therefore uh some played mover k2 which
is
more ambitious
and uh here the idea of rookie 2
yes it is a passive move but on the
other hand that there is it contains a
big
fret a5 let's say if i play something
inaccurate let's say rook d4 possibly
could be inaccurate
i have to face a5 right now and
if he plays a6 a7 i'm he will basically
promote the queen
so i figured that i have to rouge i need
to be kind of careful
and that's why i played rook c5 to
prevent
a5 because if a5 goes i take the pawn
on b5 and also i attack on d5
so this was this was okay however there
was probably even simpler way to play
for me let's for instance just b6 and
like after king 2 rook c3
and i honestly don't think that there is
any
there are any problems here for black
the
if a5 i just take and uh
we simplify further the position he
doesn't have any he doesn't have the
past pawn
uh well supported his b5 point which is
passed
which is possible but it's not well
supported as early would be in this line
for us afterward
for a5 therefore this was also quite
easy i decided
but you know my up my approach was uh my
thinking here was
okay i'm gonna simplify the position it
should end up in a draw and this is also
okay
rook c5 king e2 king e7 or king e3 rook
d5
but here we got this end game and
in here many things happened because
suddenly i figured that if anyone could
be better here like slightly slightly
better or like
visually let's say have some better
chances to win this game
is white for a simple reason there are
two pawns on the queen side and
if there is possibility and there is
higher possibility of
making the outside past pawn for white
rather than for black
who has central postpone but it doesn't
quite go anywhere because white king is
very active
and yeah so basically
this depend doesn't really go anywhere
and
if he he might have ideas rook c2 or c7
for instance if he can bring his rook
there and
somehow eliminate this pawn he'll have
two past pawns versus zero
so uh i saw this danger
you know somewhere in my calculations
but still i believe the black is
completely okay
but uh the thing is over the board when
you're playing the game
and sometimes you know you know the
positions equal but you still
face some or encounter some practical
difficulties
it is not entirely easy to react with to
those
especially with in such time controls
like a rapid game or or blitz
and if classical chess of course is way
different
but uh in rapid and blitz is also like
it's
blitz and rabbits have its own rules as
well so uh and again having roxy too
king d7 idea is of course for black uh
for why one of the ideas for y is to
play b6 and rook c7
uh however if b6
it basically over extends a little bit
the pawn structure as well
and i can play uh i think just
rook e5 check and the idea is to play at
some point rook a5 and
i'm taking this a4 pawn but starting
with this check
there like for instance the idea is that
after this this suddenly i i'll take
here on a4 with the check very often
so um or i can play
also immediately or other ideas to play
rook c5 here and i think actually r65 uh
is is the simplest so b6 doesn't
really quite lead anywhere uh
he breaking e4 rook h5 activate the rook
g3 rook e5 all those moves are pretty
standard
right now nothing really happens white
has no fret
and uh i decided right now to play with
h5 as earlier in this position just of
bringing it once again if b6 i have this
idea
or it does this rook a5 to capture the
pawn or even stronger with rook c5
uh covering the c file and if of course
takes
rook takes c5 pawn takes this pawn on c6
is simply falling
upon bc is simply falling because a5 can
be five
and i think actually black is winning
suddenly so he doesn't
achieve here anything
in this position as we had in the game
uh b6 right now after if he if he plays
b6 rooks
isn't possible anymore but i can
as i said earlier i can switch the plan
basically to the attacking a4 pawn
especially that
rook c7 doesn't come up uh come with the
attack on the h7 pawn as well
so here i can play probably just rook a5
with a pretty simple draw for instance
this
this this this this after king c3 let's
say it's pretty logical
uh i don't think i would have any
uh serious problems after the saking d5
uh this should be quite easy to draw
here uh whenever he plays this i can
play for instance this
and rook b6 rook behind the pawn is
still one of the most important
roles in the end game rogan games and
if he goes anything else like
this i can consider playing just oh wait
wait maybe the king device is a little
bit inaccurate
a little bit more uh i should be a
little bit more careful right now
but for instance i can play rook a1 and
activate my rook and bring it
up from the back and should be also a
draw let's say okay one
it should be it should be quite easy to
draw
so in this position he played rogue f2
and i saw during the game that if he
plays rogue f2 i can always play kings
and rocks
i saw this possibility of simply making
uh
the this repetition here as uh with the
king
uh king seven king seven the more very
important thing is not to allow
rook f7 invasion or rook c7 on the
seventh rank
because if i lose b7 as i said earlier
there will be two past pawns a4 b5
versus zero
so uh there's something really really to
watch out for
in this endgame for instance king e6
would be probably
already a mistake maybe or at least big
an inaccuracy because it allows rook f8
so some care is necessary as well
k7 ruger iii some waiting move
i played right now b6 in order to
make sure that the spawns are not going
anywhere he never can play a5 right now
rook b3 idea is to play a5 and push the
pawn forward i play of course king d7
and if after king d7 idea is to bring
the king
uh close enough that if a5 never works
because i will block the b5 uh
b pawn with the king for instance if he
plays right now a5 i would simply take
b6 and i have for instance king c8 one
of them one of many moves
after this i can play king b8 and i'm
completely defined here probably still a
draw
but you know at least i won the pawn and
i don't have certainly any any problems
here as black
also possibly i could consider playing
rook e8
rook b8 however this is a little bit
passive and i'm not
quite a big fan of that however it's
also possible
and here he played rook c3
and this was actually interesting moment
because
right now the fret the the thread is
rook c6 obviously
and to attack the b6 pawn and
try to win it and i had many moves
right now i can i could i can think of
three
of them right now that they could easily
play and this i'm totally fine
i chose one of them however uh the point
is
that from psychological perspective
sundays is not easy to decide
on the move in such situation because
you either
because sometimes too much choice is a
problem
like if you play uh the one one very
natural move
to me that occurred during the game was
rook e1 and this is move that i played
and it is a really good move uh
because it activates the rook and i want
to give some checks from behind and play
i'll always catch the a4 group a1
and this is totally okay
however there are other moves and one of
the moves that i consider is rook c5
but rook c5 you know in shorter time
control is very committal move because
you have to evaluate the end game
pawn and game a rising point game and if
the opponent game uh
and at the moment you are not entirely
sure because of the nerves because of
the time pressure because of the you
know
presses of the tournament and things
like that you
it's not easy to make such a communal
decision during the during the game
however uh of course rook c5 is okay
because after rook c5
when you are cool headed it's easy to
see obviously a very lazy nd5 just
cooking c7
and white has no way to make progress
even though white has
more active king because this pawns on
c5 was
supported by the b6 pawn and this king
can never go
escape the box or like the square of
this spawn on c5
and you know the game pretty much ends
with just uh repeating moves and
draw lights like kinky 5k d5 white can
never lose this but also black cannot
never win this
uh of course would be a very sketchy or
like
very suspicious at least unnecessary to
to be to be you know very precise uh to
go for this
because uh for white because here white
never
can win this only black can win this
because white black has outside postpone
and uh probably it still should be a
draw i will say very carefully
however it's uh actually it could be
already lost because there will be
scheme seven p6 a4
came before this this king c5 it is
black
that is uh simply much faster to the
king side
[Music]
and uh while black white king is uh
far away so does the power of outside
possible you can give it away and you're
then after
uh taking your open spawn your king will
be a little bit closer to the center and
the other side of the board so you're
simply faster so this uh
if my onsen is correct it could be
simply already winning for black
so this is commit is completely
unnecessary for white to go for his a5
move uh
another possible so rook c5 was
basically the simplest
but you have to uh calculate rook c5 and
evaluate it
and at the moment i didn't have you know
time we both had like
maybe you know 15 20 seconds here we
both
had like very little time we were
playing on increment
so uh in this stressful situation i
decided to play rookie one
another possibility is to play rook g5
value of playing rook g4
and attacking this a4 pawn over the
fourth rank
and this is also completely okay because
after rook c6 or g4 king d5
i can simply go back to g5
and and after but this is i think i also
saw this
but i wasn't sure after king c4
and the answer after rook c4 i cannot
play this this
because pawn a4 is defended upon b6
false
but again i have move rook c5 which i
didn't
kind of c because i dismiss it earlier
so i think they include my calculations
already here
so uh and it's basically essential
essentially the same position as earlier
because it's just
just a draw right uh yeah so
luigi five also was working so finally i
played move rookie one
and after rookie one uh rook c6 uh rook
d
it's very important to play move d1 and
the idea is to kick away our white's
king away from the center
because if for instance i played rook a1
i'll be in trouble after who takes b6
rook takes a4 and suddenly king d5 his
king would get to d5 square i don't have
check right now
pawn d6 is falling and
with it probably just explained as well
well i have some weaknesses and i don't
have check to hour to my opponent's king
and i'm pretty much lost right now so
this is very important it was
important very important check group d1
king e4 and again rook a1 right now
would be the same mistake because after
uh rook a1 group b6 rook a4 and king d5
white wins is the same position so again
i have to give another check
he goes king f4 and i go to ga1 right
now because after rook b6
in this position i go rook a4 and his
king is not coming to d5
right so uh that was the this was my
point
and after king g5 it seems like i'm
losing g6 pawn but i have rook g4 and
probably like afterwards uh h4 and
simplifying
completed the position and just it's
just just it's just a draw
so uh some played rook c4 draft
defending the pawn and it was actually
very
very very tricky move because after rook
c4
the most natural response for uh for
black is to play d5
and this was i guess his small let's say
practical trap i would say because uh
d5 is the of course the most natural
move
you know rook c4 goes back and i play d5
if he goes let's say rook d4 or
something i go king d6 active with my
king and i will have
maybe even chances to win this game
because personally my king is very
active
i have already passed pawn rook is also
very active
for what i mean is that after d5 rook d4
king d6
suddenly would black would be doing very
well i think
black would have even good chances to
win this game and
however after d5 he's not the play rook
c6 and i realized that i
may have made a mistake because after
i moved to my pawn from d6 i
allowed his king i allowed
his king to his king to get to e5 square
and mike suddenly his king is very
active rook is very active
my king is passive and even despite
winning the
i'm winning the opponent for his kings
were active and he will recapture his
pawn back
very very soon so uh this was
his trick here which i missed obviously
uh and but it's still not not
lost or anything it's just still
completely okay i made the
later in the mistake i will point out uh
where and when
uh so another possibility was here to
play king e6
and this was also okay basically
activating my king and
and this should be a draw because for
this i go d5 rook c6 king e5
rook takes b6 rook takes a4 looking into
g6 and h4
and with such active king i don't think
and and already postponed like
very advanced on d5 and you know quite
going forward going forward quite
quickly d4d3d2
um it is it seems it should be quite
easy to draw right now
as well uh all ana is later with the
engines you know after the game
is like that i discovered that it's
actually not so simple
for black to make this draw and there's
only maybe more but like one clear idea
that engine suggests which is very
difficult to find over the board
so i wouldn't criticize myself over
playing d5 too hastily
but because i think it was a good
decision
uh because here if i play this king e6
suddenly it's becoming very
tricky for instance king g5 takes takes
d4 seemingly
is just okay but what happens after v8
is the question
that if hiplane can play let's say b6 b7
and then check my king he will win right
and there is essentially one very nice
idea for black to save this game
is to play a move d3 for instance b6
rook b4 b7 seemingly i'm lost
because regate is unstoppable and right
now the move is root b5
and this is a brilliant resource for
black
the idea is that whenever the king
rookie 8 happens
there'll be some check and the pawn
the d-pawn also go forward and there
will be basically a trade for instance
of king g4
we can play probably just d2 rook d8
because he has to stop this pawn somehow
uh sorry rook b7 rook takes the rotates
d2 and king f6 and this is very very
simple draw
um so yeah this is one of the this ruby
five move here
is very important otherwise it will be
simply lost because for instance
d2 would raise the would end will result
with this
let's say i'm looking anywhere b8 queen
takes takes and after d1 queen
rook e rook d8 so basically with rook b5
we are making ourselves space to go
our king to f6 earlier uh because white
king would be on rayon g4
in this line as i said after b5 king g4
for instance
d2 and uh he reached this roach position
uh so king is also making a draw however
i played d5
rook c6 arc takes a4 king e5
and this position i sort of was already
i felt i mean i knew that it has to be a
draw like i didn't do anything wrong
in this game maybe i made some
inaccuracies of course but like i didn't
do anything terrible and
this i have this broken game with extra
pawn
even though i'm quite passive and but
i'm on the move and i know that
i knew i had to it should be a draw so
uh i played move right now h4 which
from principle point of view is correct
because the rules like no like rule of
thumb sort of
is if you simply if you trade all the
pawns there'll be no
or like as many as possible simplify as
much as possible
there will be not enough attacking
resources for your opponent to win the
game
and this was my uh reasoning behind
playing h4
there was even probably simpler move
rook g4 and
then after this rule b6 d4 but i didn't
consider this
here as i said we played already like on
increment and
five second increment which is very
little time so i decided to play h4
and after rook hg6 h3 upon take g3
i played rook b4 it was this was my idea
when i played h4
kind of like instinctively i saw the
rook before and after rook b6
that uh he cannot defend this g-free
point after moved like group g4
and this was instinctively instinctively
what i
saw that uh he cannot defend this pawn
and i'm simply collecting g-free pawn
and my king is very close to the queen's
queen side and it's just a draw
but suddenly it is not so simple
and actually i'm lost here and i will
see i will show in a moment why
so uh in this position the the only path
to
you know to draw right now for black is
to play move d4
and uh of course i didn't consider this
move uh
only move that consider was g4 as i said
but we
we were both playing on increment five
second increments and we had no time
here to think whatsoever uh
so or like to think too deeply so just
kind of insta i intuitively played
rook g4 and uh you know thinking that
i'm just collecting g free point as the
draw
but my calculation was wrong right now
so uh
instead if i play move d4 right now king
e4
and now king c7 this would be a draw
because right now
uh he cannot first of all he cannot
allow my pawn to
go forward too much and if he collects
this
deep on uh with his rook he will drop b5
pawn and that's the
main reason for for it to be a draw we
have to stop the pawn of the king
and if i play king c7 right now
rook c6 i go simply quick king d7 and
there is some certain issue with this b5
pawn
here he cannot really resolve it easily
because if he plays rook c5 just go king
d6
if he goes d5 you just go king e6 and
whenever he takes d4 pawn i take b5 pawn
and it's just immediate draw
however one thing i want to point out
seemingly after you know this d4 like
last two moves d4
king e4 d3 would be a making a draw
right
like uh it seems like you know
just pawn trade you take king d take him
to d3 rugby
free king c4 g3 and uh
you know we simplified totally the
position it can be even
nearly more simplified and you know
there is b
pawn uh which theoretically should be
uh you know
not should be drawn basically this
energy and you know
normally this angle should be drawn if
only black king is uh close enough to
the pawn
it seems like this king this king is
close to the pawn uh
because on d7 it's like you know only c7
could be closer right
but this is the thing suddenly it's not
close enough
after right now white move rook c6
it is winning for white because white
king suddenly
sorry black king is suddenly cut on the
c file and the
white there is no way to stop blocking
from going forward
and then if the white king goes forward
it's basically theoretical position
of building a bridge
and it's simply it's simply winning just
to show
uh for for example is one of the most
well-known
and rokan games so with rook g4 let's
say king c5
let's say here just it doesn't quite
matter just lost after anything
this this b6 pawn there is no way to
stop the spawn
rook c1 for instance uh
rook eight i mean anything rogue a2
let's say check
king goes here look c2 king b8 this
this and for instance rook a2
and again right now the way to win this
for y is to play move rook d4
and the idea is that after move like
rook a1 we simply go with the king
and finally that while this way we need
rook on d4 because i ran out of play
room before and
we cover we sort of build a bridge it's
called i know why it's called the bridge
but like it's called a bridge
uh on before and palm b7 promotes the
queen there is no way to stop that
so this will be after c6 right now
theoretically winning position
uh so even in such simple end games
seemingly there are still lots of tricks
and that's
that's the main reason why everyone
should play i guess and games till the
end
because there's always some room for
error even with the simple ones
in the simple end games so uh also or
also over here i play movie g4 seemingly
the most natural move right and i
basically broke g4 i attacked the g free
point i want to eliminate it and
just immediate draw right well not so
easy suddenly uh
he can he played move uh he played right
now he played ruby seven
after king cr7 g3 i achieved my goal and
this is
this is just that draw because my king
is right now
very close to the b pawn and i'm
build sort of philidor's position this
you know field version of b pawn which
is even
let's say simpler than you know the one
with the d-pawn let's say
because right now i don't have to even
keep my rook on the sixth frame i can't
even keep my work on the eighth ring and
there is no way
white could win that uh but you know
rogan's his six dragon is basically
field or fielder's position which is
what were very well known and obviously
it's obviously a draw
so this would happen in the game however
here some could have played
a move that basically wins the game on
the spot
however you know it's hard to blame him
or whatever because like we both had
like here
for a few seconds so uh anyone can make
such a mistake
so the winning move was hero d6 and
seemingly there is no big difference
between those tracks rook d6 or
b7 but the point is that after rook d6
king c7 after king e7 for instance
the king would be very far away so we
would basically likely
reach the position of which we discussed
earlier
with the king being you know very far
away from the pawn and then
people will be deciding uh
after king c7 the problem is that right
now rook c6 follows
and after king b7 rook c3 suddenly
and uh he manages to protect his g free
pawn
and i didn't get to get to win b51 as
well
for instance and white is winning right
now after d4 for instance rupee three i
think is the the simplest move
because just to keep both pawns covered
and after king b6
simply king d5
i have pretty much no move i cannot move
anywhere in my room because i drop this
d4 pawn if i move the king
he basically brings his king even
further
to the b5 pawn and i cannot
kind of allow that to happen as well so
if d3 i tried to distract his rook he
takes takes
and right now king is sick suddenly my
king is right now too far away
and probably would end up
again either with the bridge position
or you know just just the king is too
far away
there is no way to stop this uh king and
pawn uh set up
because just king is too far away so uh
yeah this is uh this was very very tough
uh right now would be very very tough
uh for me right now after wikiforce
played with d6 probably will be just
just just being for white and he would
have won the game
but uh i guess i got lucky right now and
he played ruby seven
king c8 rook h7 and this was just very
simple draw
here we played till the end obviously
but uh
the game ended here because it's style
mate so
this was it and despite it being very
very
seemingly boring end game initially
suddenly became very
interesting so i found this very
instructive and that's why
i wanted to bring it up during this
class during this class and um
yeah so next game i wanted to talk about
i'm not sure how much time we have i
think we have
more time for one more game um
is my game it's my game against sam
shankland
and this time i was on the let's say um
side that was close to very close to
winning actually
uh first of all i was winning in the
middle game then i made a mistake
and i he escaped into the rook
and game with less pawns uh less
material
but with active pieces and i didn't
manage to convert it into
a win unfortunately however the position
i would like to talk about
is
this one at first so last move was king
f1
and for here i thought i'm simply going
to have to play move f4
and i simply disconnect the queen from
the c4 pawn i play queen takes c4 next
and i'm assuming you're just collecting
the entire house
like just one pawn after another making
is safe his king is not safe
seemingly i thought i'm just completely
winning right now and uh
the truth the truth is that indeed i am
but i need to still prove it
so in the game after g1 which was pretty
much only move
uh queen c4 king g2 f3 and yeah i
thought that uh
you know i can transfer to the rook and
game right now with several
extra pawns like two extra pawns and
after because after this this this i
collect on f6 and he doesn't have time
to play rook takes b6 which is what i
saw
because i play rook h6 and after king g5
i go to g6 and rook on g1 falls
but he played very quickly g4 and
suddenly i
started realizing that
it's not entirely trivial to win this
despite it being uh
two extra points for me my palms are not
well uh guarded and suddenly
his pieces are immediately posing laws
of thrust to them
and i cannot easily may also make uh
create a past pawn or like you know
stabilize the position
because i have possible h7 plus pawn but
it's still on h7 only
and he can attack or trade some pawns
and simplify the position further and
has he i think white has suddenly has
decent chances
to make a draw here so i
kind of panicked right now because i saw
that i'm completely winning suddenly
there is rook end game which i thought
is completely winning but then i see
like how do i defend
b6 pawn like if he and if i defend uh he
will activate his rook to the d file
let's say and he'll enter for the
seventh rank
and uh always he can play king g3 and
call my free point at some point
so i stare i noticed uh some practical
difficulties i'm facing here
and i realized that it's not so easy to
win this
and unfortunately i unfortunately i
immediately went wrong
right now because i played move b5
and b5 was a big mistake because
after b5 he can simply play he could
simply play a4
and this is exactly what i said uh
pretty much the game
i'm the you know he he trades one
one pair of pawns and the likelihood of
further trace is
dramatically increased let's say if i
take play can play with b6
if i play let's say rook c5 one of the
possible moves for instance
is rook d1 and attacking go through the
back rank so i have to respond to that
somehow also he can take it he take here
at first then play rook a1 or something
so uh there are over there maybe you're
okay one
uh so there are certain basically
problems that
uh with converting this into a win
so um i played this b5 which was a
mistake but uh
come but let's think about this position
uh for a second
and try to understand what could be the
winning or like you know possibly
a good plan for uh for black to win the
to win this
and uh after you know like starting this
position because i was very curious
what's happening in his endgame
um it kind of like it
didn't give it wasn't giving me a piece
kind of like how
is it really because a draw or is this
is there is really such a good chance
for black for white to make a draw here
or if it's a draw really or or indeed i
have
i i should have some good chances to win
this game as black
and the analytical approach uh proved
that
indeed black has very good chances to
win this but
in reality it's never never easy and the
reason for this is business activity
wise
white rooks are very active and my pawns
are
not well placed they are constantly
under some attack
and the probability of traits of let's
say pawns on the queen side because
there are two rooks on the board and
pawn on f3 basically being
too far away uh and like if the one pair
of rooks
is being traded and pawn free will
follow likely
all those factors contribute to the fact
that it is not easy to win this position
with black however with correct play and
best play
computers the engines show that indeed
black is
blackish black should win in the end but
as i said
practical level is never easy so um
e5 so right now if i was the best move
the best attempt to
play for a win and the reason why e5 not
b5 is that b5
allows you know undermining of this pawn
structure on the queen side
uh with a4 right
and if i play e5 this is not possible i
covered b6 pawn
through my rook on f6 but i didn't kind
of like this move because
i thought the leaves e5 may be
vulnerable in some lines
but i can of course easily defend that
after rookie one uh rookie eight for
instance
and uh rookie three very logical move
rook f5 for instance i can play
and the idea is that whenever he goes
let's say move like king g3 i can play
h4
h5 and this should be winning also the
point is
that i try for instance after a4
you know one of them let's say logical
moves i would be
i have an idea here to basically trade
one pair of ropes in very good version
for me
for instance after a4 i was analyzing
like a five rook ee4
trying to play roxy for c6 but right now
i think that rook g8
would be winning for me because the
thing is after this this
i've basically rook c4 i play rook f4
and this pawn end game
is winning for uh for black
for the same reason we discussed earlier
against my game
in my game against sam savion because
right now i have the outside passport on
the h7
and he will even though he collects
those two pawns
i will i'm more than happy to give them
as long as i keep the h7 pawn
because then h7 will destroy white king
uh
from defending f2 pawn and then after
trade of h7 pawn for f2 pawn
uh my king will be closer to the queen
side and i win the
following end game for instance after
this this let's say
this this this um i'm requires
calculation still obviously
but it should be quite easily winning
let's after h5 this
and with king g3 he cannot go too far
away because
h pawn will pronounce the queen so let's
say this and finally h4
and finally something like this would
certainly
be winning for black because i'm just
simply way closer to the queen side than
white king is
so that's the reason why this idea of
rook g8 would be winning so um
of course this i had no i had no clue
about such lines during the game i
basically made a million immediate
mistake but for the educational purpose
i was
to learn on my own uh i wanted to learn
how to
basically approach such position and
basically the point is at first
secure all your pawns and then try to
win uh try to trade one pair of rooks
and then if they can create some threats
uh trying to make more uh
try to eventually either trade second
pair of rooks or you know
if if it's not possible uh to trade one
pair of rocks to at least
stabilize all the pawn structure and
make them the well defended and
improve the king so this would be just
general some some general strategy
i thought that c4 was a free or rook b3
maybe at that arrow here ruby free
b3 try to attack both pawns would be a
feasible defensive resource for
for white uh and indeed
it is but still black has some very good
chances to win
and for instance a5
rook g4 idea is to make sure that
everything is protected as i said
i want to play rook e6 a5 i want to have
everything totally protected
and then if it's all protected then i
can slowly improve maybe trade one pair
of rocks improve my king only then
if it's on product it will be always
constantly under attack
so uh rookie four king g7 rook b3
rook e6 rook b5 and the idea is to play
move c5 or something like this
and i thought it's not so easy here to
win this position as well
and probably uh with
best play black can win this after move
rook c6 but for instance you know the
very typical
king f6 already doesn't lead anywhere c5
rock c5
uh pawn iphoto is just you know very
weak if we have lyric a6 my rooks are
very passive
pawn only three as i said doesn't really
help me to uh
help help you know with converting this
end game
so uh suddenly white has great chances
to save this game
also idea after okay six rook a4 for
instance would basically
uh sort of nearly clinch the draw i
guess
uh i don't know like
it is very unlikely that i would win
that was black would technically win
this
so instead i thought roxy six 6
would be you know good try for this good
try for
black to win this and after this this
this
king g3 try to win this end game however
after this this qr king g6 rook d5
rook b for the second f3 i we would
achieve let's say such
i mean by the way this is all announces
with the
with engine so there is hardly room for
improvement for any of the sites
and according to the engines right now
h5
is gives black decent chances to win
this game
however over the board is not clear to
me whatsoever
if it's winning or if it's if this is a
win or not
because the material is really reduced
to you know uh i'm not i'm not two
pounds i don't
i don't have two extra pawns only only
one extra pawn
and probability of trading a pawn for
let's say b6
a a2 pawn for b6 pawn or maybe
f for h pawns it's quite substantial
i don't know anything could happen of
course black has decent chances to win
this
but by far uh is i wouldn't say 100 is
winning or or something definitely good
chances for black two for win but if
it's winning
i am not entirely sure at least so this
was the best way to play as
i'll outside again uh all the
blacks moves here to play e5 rook e8
let's say
then a5 here and rookie six all those
moves had one uh
one goal in mind to make sure everything
is protected and then at some point
trade the pair of rooks
and improve the king and so on but at
first
guard everything and unfortunately this
is not what i did in the game
because i played move b5 and he could
have played immediately a4 which would
result in a you know nearly immediate
draw
i was like i played b5 then i saw a4
like what am i doing after a4 like it's
just immediate draw
uh but he didn't do it he played rook d1
which was a little bit inaccurate
still doesn't spoil really much but
it gives me some again chances to play
this move e5
and after g7 let's say rook g8
with some good chances to let's say you
know
put some fight here it was uh
two for a win it was still decent
chances but
again he because he made a mistake uh
the zero and i didn't again capitalize
on and here i sort of you know
panicked or i don't have to explain what
was going through my mind
i played your h6 i i decided three loops
too early
and as you can probably see after this
this rook d6
suddenly all my phones are falling even
though i have two extra pawns
i'm losing uh one of them and
if i had for instance already in this
push my rook on c6 yes this will be
very good idea to play this because then
i uh have all my pawns protected and
i should have may even if it's not
winning objectively
i should have very very good chances to
win this in this this rocket game
but of course my results six and after
he played with d6
i it was just basically a draw so we
played it up till the end after a5
this this we played it out
till the end it's just quite simple draw
right now after
a4 a3 or k1 and yeah
i mean this is just a draw i have i
believe i'd play two
because whenever i move my king i will
drop this
g6 pawn which is what i didn't want but
if i play a2 i have simply no way to
improve this position because
he just can stay with his rook he can
even just give this
a four point i don't he doesn't need it
too different to make a draw
and this is just theoretical or we just
play it out but like
of course just that draw so the only
thing that i would like to say
it would be winning with the white black
one on f6 or on f5 somewhere
because then i will have possibility of
playing f3 at some point sacrificing a
pawn
and kicking his king out of g2 and h2
squares which would allow me to
create i mean to basically check his
king somehow either from the side or
from the back on f1
but of course just to quickly show it
it's probably the last portion i want to
show
um if let's say
i put this pawn here on f6
this would be certainly winning right
now for black because let's say if f5
i can move my king anywhere doesn't
quite matter f4
let's say whatever rook a7 f3 this is
the
this will be the idea for black but of
course on g5 is not possible
but let's say if he takes i would play
rook f1 the white blind move
by takes pork f1 if king f2 uh rook h1
rook surgery 2
h2 is the winning idea here for black of
course all well known
i'm sure many of you know it just want
to point out because it was just some
you know i just found the utility for
to show it because it's very similar
this was different
was the difference between pawns on f6
and g6
or f and g5 so this is how the game
ended
with the pawn on jifa obviously on f and
i had no way to
make it make any progress here and we
just we played out till the end like
maybe 20 more moves or something and we
finally agree to a draw
or actually you know it was like we
played up to
the two kings and yeah it was a draw
so yeah i think that's uh
pretty much all i had for today uh i
mean did i
i had my mom i had as i said initially i
had more end games
to show from this end game from this
tournament
all very interesting uh for example uh
my game against hikaru nakamura and
alejandro ramirez were exceptionally
interesting and
i'm more than happy to discuss them next
time
however for now i think that gmail games
against two sums
some seven and some shankland were also
very interesting and
they had some educational value so uh
that's all for today from me
and i'll see you next time thank you
take care have a good evening